it's August 1st 2017 and it's time for
another monthly update video so I'm
going to talk about all the cool stuff
we've got coming up in August and all
the stuff that happened in July I always
like to begin by talking about three big
things that I want to put on your radar
so big thing number one philosophy pop
up so I'm going to talk more about this
in the August portion but just let me
say right here we're going to use
YouTube and Facebook to do some video
conferencing it'll be announced well
ahead of time and patreon but just the
day of the pop-up in the other social
media big thing number two we had to put
off the start webinar and seminars and
we will be doing those this month so if
you've ever wanted to understand
jean-paul sartre conceptions of human
freedom and responsibilities as you find
it in being a nothingness and some of
these other works you definitely want to
be in on those and the third thing
another holdover from previous months
we're finally going to get that
Aristotle categories course finished
polished out there in the reason IO
Academy so what went on in the month of
July it was a very busy month but I
didn't get quite as much done in part
because I was preoccupied with a number
of other things some of which were very
good and some of which were not so good
so my kids were here and I loved having
them here in the summer but of course
that meant that I cut my working time
down to about half the normal amount
that I would be putting in which really
wouldn't have presented that big of an
issue except for the fact that each of
my kids and myself and my wife all got
sick times over the month of July some
of us more seriously than others I lost
probably a good week or so just on my
own account you know with a bad sinus
infection and other things that went
with and some of them were sick or yet
than me I also had my
laptop which I've had for a number of
years go kaput and it took you know
about three-four days of not booting up
properly and freezing up and trying this
and trying that and trying this and
trying that before we finally took it in
to the Apple store fortunately we have
one here why because in the past we've
had to like drive an hour or two to get
to one and long story short they ended
up having to replace it they ran a
number of Diagnostics on it they were
never never able to figure out exactly
what was wrong with it so goods you know
good results I actually have a new
laptop but I lost three weeks where I
couldn't get a lot of writing done or or
course production because it turns out
that I am incredibly dependent on having
a laptop so that was sort of prelude to
what was going on in July we were going
to have a session in the world of
speculative fiction on Octavia Butler I
had to cancel that due to illness
because I got sick so that is going to
be rescheduled for December and so fans
of Butler you can look forward to that I
did manage to meet for our you know our
Mk II that's Milwaukee stoic fellowship
I did manage to go to our shut up and
write sessions here
in the downtown I did manage to host the
online half-hour Hegel and philosophy
chat but I but I also put off one of the
online events until this monthly start
webinars and seven eyes again due to
illness so you know not a lot of events
during during July and I did have a few
other interesting things happen an
interview with the daily stoic that's
Ryan holidays site came out and
interview with me I also had another
interview podcast with the how to think
like a thought leader podcast Samuel
Osborne's site and so those are pretty
fun stuff I got to do some reflection on
my work and what it is that I do so if
you're interested in that sort of thing
you look for the links below
I did get some writing done before my
computer
caput and I did get some course building
done likewise as well I did engage in a
lot of philosophical counseling tutoring
and consulting by the way if you're
interested in tutorials or you're
interested in philosophical counseling
you can go to the reason IO website and
check it out I am taking on new clients
particularly particularly as we head
into you know the fall you can also
email me directly at Gregg at reason io
comm videos I shot quite a few videos
not having the laptop did not turn out
to be an impediment for that because I
do most of my video editing you know up
here in in my study on this this Big Mac
that I'm recording on right now so I
shot a number of core concept videos on
a very important work by Martin
Heidegger a lot of people been watching
those and enjoying those I'm very
pleased to see that that is what is
metaphysics I also shot some half some
some core concept videos specifically on
Hegel leading into the master-slave
dialectic and I release those early for
my half hour Hegel patreon supporters if
you're interested in that you can see
the link to that below I've started
releasing them just yesterday so you can
see where those are going my half hour
Hegel project we we got through the
entirety of the first section of spirit
finishing up with with legal status
that's again the half hour Hegel
supporters get to see those with several
weeks before the general public does but
those will be coming out this month so
you can see them and I even did out of a
supposed frustration a personal video
about the laptop issue and how dependent
I am on the laptop so that was July what
have we got coming up in the month of
August so it's going to be an
extraordinarily busy month because I'm
doing a bit of catch-up and I have a lot
of other projects ongoing a lot of cool
stuff so I'm really excited about this
and I'm feeling good
heading into the month I've started
working out regularly you know we're
doing some some fun stuff now that the
kids are gone you know it's a lot easier
to not be cooking on the fly and then
put some real thought into all of that
so what do you guys want to know about I
imagine that you're probably interested
to hear about the philosophy pop ups and
this is something that we're going to
start experimenting with we're going to
use YouTube live and we're going to use
Facebook fit you know the same same sort
of thing to do some streaming we're all
do a very short presentation on
something that I've been working on
recently like say the Heidegger videos
and then I'll open it up for questions
and I'll chat with fans and subscribers
and viewers for maybe about half an hour
or so and that it'll be recorded and
it'll go in you know and you can watch
it later if you missed it and if this
turns out to be something that people
like well then we'll continue it and we
may even start doing some in-person
philosophy pop-ups down the line but
that I'm not going to talk about that
yet
when are they going to be well this is
an incentive to become a patreon
supporter even at the $1.00 per month
level because I will be announcing it to
them today or tomorrow when these
pop-ups are going to be and for
everybody else I will be announcing them
the day of the pop-up in my social media
so that you can jump in and participate
in them so that's you know there's no
fix well there are fixed dates or them
but but we'll tell you what they are
later on today I have for anybody who's
local a presentation on Thomas Hobbes
the English Civil War and the beginnings
of modern political theory part of this
philosophers in the midst of history
series that I've been doing with the
Frank Weinberg library that is at 6:00
p.m. here in Mequon at the Frank
Weinberg like I said on the 8th which is
a week from today at 5:00 p.m. we'll
have our public half-hour Hegel
discussion and
you in a session so if you have any
questions confusions concerns about
Hegel the phenomenology German idealism
other things connected to that or you
just want to hear other people chat
about that sort of thing you want to
come to 5 p.m. Central Time
and I put the link we use our reason il
freeconferencecall.com for that on the
10th here locally as part of the world
the speculative fiction series I have a
really big lecture coming up that I have
been anticipating the entire year
because he's one of my favorite authors
I've been reading him since I was a kid
HP Lovecraft I'll be talking about the
universe the narrative universe that HP
Lovecraft develops for us and hopefully
we'll have a lot of great discussion
there may be people showing up we're
like I don't know what the hell this guy
was talking about so I may be doing some
explanation as well shifting forward
deeper into the month on the 22nd that's
a Tuesday at 11:00 a.m. Central Standard
Time we will be having our webinar our
free webinar jean-paul sartre on human
freedom and responsibility that's open
to anybody last 45 minutes I reserved a
good bit of it for Question and Answer
and we'll of course if you miss it I'll
put it online so you can you can watch
it later the 24th which is a Thursday
6:00 p.m. at the Shorewood Public
Library we have our monthly MKE stoic
fellowship meeting and we're going to be
finishing up with the enchiridion and
talking about where we want to go next
for September and what we want to do
during stoical week in October so that's
going to be a really important meeting
and then finally wrapping up on the 26th
which is a Saturday we will have our -
not quite back-to-back there's a bit of
time in between them 10:00 a.m. 4:00
p.m. Central Standard Time on line
intensive seminars each of them lasting
two hours on jean-paul sartre freedom
and responsibility doing a much deeper
dive into the material than we do in the
free webinar so if you're interested in
that you want to sign up for a slot that
is going to be a really really great set
of events what else have I got going on
a lot of writing projects this month I
didn't get any any real blogging done
last month in parks I didn't have my
laptop for three-quarters of the month
but I am going to be doing quite a lot
of blog writing this month I did stay on
top of Stoicism today which I'm the
editor of and I will be you know doing
work with that as well but I'm also
going to be writing in partially
examined life erectus T attic a half
hour Hegel heavy metal philosopher
perhaps a few other venues as well and
I'm doing some intensive writing on
several book projects I had one which
was pitched to me which i think is a
great idea and we're in the development
stage for that tell you more about that
down the line but I'm also working very
heavily on the stoicism and what does in
accordance with nature short book doing
a little bit of chipping away at the
anger and stoicism book and I'm doing
some collaborative writing with some
other people about interesting topics
and stoicism as well I'm anticipating a
lot of philosophical counseling
consulting and tutoring this month like
I said I do have openings so if you're
interested in that sort of thing
reach out to me directly just email me
Greg at reason IO calm or go to the
reason IO website where you can see the
services that I offer and whether
they're the sort of thing that you'd be
interested in videos so this month I'm
going to try to you know get my
half-hour Haegele work done fairly early
and maybe even get a little bit ahead on
that as we move into this new section of
Spirit I'll also be recording the the
event video so the thomas hobbes the HP
Lovecraft and on the Sartre webinar but
I'm also going to be working on a lot of
core cons
videos so I'm still shooting Hegel core
concept you know leading up to the
master-slave dialectic I will be
shooting more Heidegger stuff from being
in time the introduction to being in
time I know a lot of people are very
excited about that
hoping to shoot some Nietzsche material
towards the end of the month I'm not
quite sure whether it's going to be from
genealogy or you know birth tragedy or
perhaps some of the shorter essays or
perhaps some of the other words I have
to figure that out
and if I if I have the time I do want to
shoot some core concept video footage on
Gabriela Marcel there's some interesting
topics in there that some of my clients
have been asking about so I thought it'd
be kind of cool for them I'm also
starting something new that you can look
forward to actually two new things one
of them is that I'm going to start
reviewing books and I'm interested
primarily in reviewing books that have
to do with using philosophy in our lives
so you know I've got quite a stock of
books people have been sending me I'll
be doing reviews and Goodreads and
Amazon as well but I want to start doing
some video reviews and talking about
books that I think are very interesting
but I'll be using sort of the critical
perspective I'm not just going to be
cheerleading for these books I'll be
talking about what I think is good and
what's not so good in that the other
thing I'm going to do is I've decided
that we won't have a series called
Sandler's soapbox and if you know what a
traditional soapboxes it's the thing
that in a crowd at a street the person
who wanted to you know say a few things
would stand on top of and then start
their rant or their diatribe or their
critique or whatever and I have quite a
few things that I have been wanting to
talk about for a while and I think that
would be a great format for that so stay
tuned for some of those this month
I'll also be shooting a few personal
videos you know I've been reflecting a
lot about you know a few things
and as I spent time particularly with
the kids over the summer so that's
something to look forward to as well
hope that you have a great month of
August we're lined up you know knock on
wood to have a great month ourselves
very productive I hope that you have a
great time
Oh last thing that I'll mention it's my
birthday
also this month so be turning 47 kind of
not you know it's not a milestone but
hopefully you know that'll be the
offering in a great new year and I hope
that you have a great month and I'll see
you in the ether somewhere